the commissioner described the
preemptive arrest of six
anti-monarchists as unfortunate but he
said it was the only use of tough new
anti-protest laws the group were
unloading placards from a van we were
informed once they found some luggage
straps that we were going to use to
secure those placards to control these
and bring them down to try the square
for protests and our supporters there
that we were to be detained under
Section 3 of the public order act
locking on and we were then taken into
custody or between 16 and 17 hours
police said that on the eve of the
coronation they were so worried about
disruption the Home Secretary and the
mayor were given late night intelligence
briefings
the commissioner wrote in the evening
standard we found people in possession
of possible lock-on devices and people
that appeared to be purporting to be
stewards of the event in possession of
plastic bottles containing white paint
which we believe were specifically to be
used to criminally disrupt the
procession and resulted in arrests for
going equipped to commit criminal damage
in a letter to the commissioner the
mayor of London one of his political
Masters said he was grateful there was
no disruption that he demanded urgent
answers to his concerns over the arrest
of those six Republic supporters
foreign
s were rushed through last week in the
wake of regular disruption caused by
climate activists just stop oil police
now have powers to arrest protesters for
blocking transport hubs and energy
installations and to search them without
Reasonable Suspicion as we've seen over
the last weeks and months there are lots
of instances of people's day-to-day
lives being seriously disrupted by
protesters and people have rightly asked
well why isn't that being stopped so it
is right that the government gives the
police the powers to deal with those
things but again those are operational
decisions for the police on the ground
at the time why am I being arrested over
the coronation weekend police arrested
64 people 52 of them suspected of
plotting disruption
Martin brunt Sky News Scotland Yard